citizens
of the reject nation
i thought it was done
i thought
we wouldn't hear anymore
why
why won't ezra miller stop
[Laughter]
why
you gotta go big what is what is going
on ezra what isn't going on ezra come on
ezra what are you doing buddy work with
me ezra give me something we want to
give you the benefit of the down you
make it so hard i've even said as much
as i don't like this ezra miller i've
seen that flash trailer and i'm like the
movie looks cool though
i'll do my best to separate myself
because so many people worked on that
film more than just ezra yes but man
you're making this challenge yes
i am going to be conflicted to say the
least walking into that i thought this
was done
nope all right this comes from variety
i'm just gonna read this one paragraph
it sums up the whole thing keep in mind
this is just one out of i think 2 000
things that have occurred recently
and i understand there's this defense
out there and like i'm friends with
someone uh who works with actually flash
film news who's presenting evidence
against certain topics that may have
been actually not as accurate as
portrayed by media so
like there's still a lot of other things
though
that's good to have
a lot of evidence according to the
police report vermont state police were
notified of a burglary complaint from a
residence in stamford at 5 55 p.m right
on the dot in all fives police found
that several bottles of alcohol were
taken from the residence while the
homeowners were not
present
after collecting statements and looking
at surveillance videos police found
probable cause
to charge miller with felony burglary
into an unoccupied dwelling nice
they issued a citation to appear in
vermont superior record on september
26th for arraignment
what's ezra miller doing stealing
who was she
why does ezra miller need a steal did
you lose your id buddy i mean you don't
look that young i'm i mean i thought
you're getting paid well done a lot of
work yeah how did you spend all that
justice league and harry potter money
you can't be ta strapped for cash did we
miss this story because this is saying
this came out on may 1st yeah but i'm
like what there was a whole other thing
that happened in this whole time
the only thing i've heard since the last
time we covered this was that ezra
miller has been reportedly roaming the
country in a bulletproof vest carrying a
gun like it just sounds like kung fu out
there i mean like this seems like if
they have you know after collecting
statements and surveillance videos it
seems like it's pretty damning evidence
to convict someone with a felony charge
right yeah i love how they word that too
like after looking at surveillance and
other things there's probable cause to
assume i mean you mean to say that you
size for miller on videotape
breaking and entering and stealing
people's liquor cabinet just through the
wide variety of things that have
happened warner brothers i know we've
had our ups and downs in our
relationship
with
certain things have been handled as of
late but come on
you gotta let ezra go make a statement
for the love of god
you're talking about so many things
right now this elephant is bigger than
the entire building
last we heard from zazoff about the
flash was that it's a great movie got
faith in it it's good to hear i'm glad
it's a good movie you gotta let ezra go
after the movie comes out then i
understand if you can't reshoot it i
understand if it lines up with your dc
universe thingy but no more fantastic
beasts yes hey i think zazlab's already
gonna can it knowing the way how the box
office performances on those films i
think zoslav's gonna go ax that not
making enough money we think harry
potter universe can be better secondly
secondly when it comes to the flash
you just gotta do it this the image has
been staying i thought you want to
reinvent the dc brand i thought you want
to protect the dc brand
and it starts with not letting
criminals
start in your movies
which you've had remarkable trouble uh
doing what is the point of stealing
always strikes me the weirdest when
celebrities steal yeah i know it's like
it's somehow less weird when you're
berating people about like the the rasta
origins of parcheesi and yet when you're
like
really you're doing some like high
school [ __ ] how could you not have a
person or a few bucks i mean home
invasion break-ins are a terrifying
experience to inflict on to someone just
to know that someone could break into
your home
and steal stuff meaning they can break
into your home when you're there or when
you're asleep so it's scary as much
jokes as who we've made
home invasion's terrible you had a
situation just last night you had a
situation yeah there was a guy walking
around our neighborhood like coming up
to everyone's door like slamming on
certain people's doors like looking into
the doorbell camera and everything just
like lingering there was very strange to
behold and you're like yeah is this guy
gonna try and bust him through a window
or something and that could be a very
stressful situation that could be a
strain it can cause panic anxiety all
kinds of worries and fears i don't know
what the emotional individual's response
is to what happened with this burglary
break-in however ezra miller didn't know
who was so you
not know about their emotional
well-being and that's been the problem
with a lot of what's been happening with
ezra miller because this does go into
the form of terrorizing someone still
even though this is not a physical
attack like like directly injuring
someone that's still endangering man
that's still messed up yeah it still
shouldn't be happening you're still
violating people's space as much jokes
especially on the whole thing of
stealing like experts don't worry the
property value is going to go up because
the celebrity broke into the house
it's still a really messed up thing to
do so man you gotta can this individual
like like say something because that's
just say something like i'm not the kind
to be like you know it's it's of vital
importance when corporations or things
like make statements about you know
social issues but in this case it would
be good for you guys for whatever role
model position that you have to be and
at least come out and say hey we don't
support this individual and we would not
be working with them post the flash like
how hard would it be to just say that
guys
we'll see you next time you guys are
like the media's spinning stuff hey
innocent until proven guilty i haven't
seen the video so maybe you're right
i'll wait these people did but i've also
been saying
there's something messed up yeah there's
more to this story here yeah they were
at the bar in hawaii that was refusing
to service yeah so then he was like i'm
going to go to your house
for fun as far from hawaii in america as
we could get might just be completely
wrong about it
and we will own up if we are but right
now let them go all right that's all for
today folks but uh hey before we go
who's the fortunate one to get a
lance door lance shouting you out
because you're in law enforcement why
are you slacking get off your lazy ass
man you could be out there making a
difference you watch all these superhero
movies spring in action you had a kid
not long ago it's time to make your kid
proud shut up
be a role model
make sure you this person is not
committing any more crimes
come on you could probably hog tie them
up with the with the fire hose or
something intimidate with an axe yeah
leave them on the police's doorstep like
a batman would yeah come on lance you're
you're
you're slacking out there you are
letting america down yeah all right
america's love is counting on you but
lance thank you for being here you've
been uh one hell of a loyal supporter of
us
love you if you ever want to steal from
us
that's fine just don't take the liquor
just don't take the lecture
i pay fifteen dollars a month
[Music]